because we we have to cover this it's i
i i don't really like to do date in two
days in a row but this is one of these
situations where we have to
so as we find out yesterday our our uh
friend dayton hypernova um
his brother died sherman died of a liver
of liver failure
um now from what everything i'm seeing
it's because of excessive drinking
and other kind of you know again that
has to be a lot of drinking
something else is i don't know still
bugs probably a lot of drinking
so uh
[Applause]
this is uh this is from kate dorian
paradoxes aka earl
aka daytona i already read ahead and i'm
already [ __ ]
i hate him so as we know a little quick
backstory after sherman died
um his brother his as he calls him
pseudo-liberal brother from seattle came
to visit and uh this is what uh earl
says
it's devastating that people in this
family literally make no effort to
console the constant victim of the
skinhead after seven and a half years
in fact my recordings of them downstairs
are almost entirely cheery in tone
there was a little crying for a moment
but it's mostly just
happy conversations not one mention of
how devastating his life
in this house was i'm sure it's because
none of them believe in seeking
counseling to better their psychological
balance
i mostly just done even trying to record
them it's sad
circumstances made me a spy in my home
life
awful now
here's what's happening there was crying
what happens is when you have family get
together when you lose a loved one and
i'm sure you know about this and
we've i've dealt with as i'll deal with
this people cry
but then you naturally start talking
about good things with the people you
know yeah of course
you laughing does happen it's a way of
healing it it's like oh man hey you know
man i'm going to miss sure remember that
time
remember that time on thanksgiving that
he did blah blah blah blah blah
that happens that's just a natural part
in dealing with death it's you know you
you have ups and downs where you're
crying and when you remember and then
you remember you cry it's
it's all those things like we're irish
in my family the amount of laughter
versus crying is that would actually
disturb outsiders i think
so then he continues here in another
post um
oh god my family are bad bad people i
didn't have my camera on just now
because my purse
my purse full of sun chips an aluminum
foil
was away and i think i was in bed trying
to sleep
trying to seem asleep lights out and my
bigot neutral as hell
at anti-trans violence older sister came
into my room
and she all she could say was i know you
have a lot of conflicting emotions
we all have a lot of conflicting
emotions and her voice was outright
quivering
avoiding the fact that she's talking
about herself and seven years of
ignoring repeated beatings by a man
twice my size in the house across the
street from her jesus christ
i didn't flinch or open my eyes so she
has nothing but herself
to talking to dead air no sense in
herself of finding solace about trying
to talk to me considering
that's her pathetic totally neutral
words the way trump words
remind remained so damn neutral as the
neon
as the neon our older brother praised
it's awful seven years of psychological
agony
of them shunning me until finally at
this death
that finally at his death is awful i'm
shocked
from this family so i don't even have
the proper emotional reaction to this
insane [ __ ] even as i type it the the
amount of
me me me me me me going on is is
i've never seen levels of this before
this is this is a whole new level of
this [ __ ]
so the next one the most important thing
is that by not participating today and
staying upstairs away from my family
it makes it clear in their souls that
they are wrong and have always been the
wrong ones for seven
seven and a half goddamn years of this
transphobic beatings harassment
gaslighting belittlements arrogance etc
and that will only damn them more
with time but you're
he they're not they're not feeling any
punishment
from a lack of you being around like i'm
sure they're perfectly fine
with you deciding not to be around and
the fact that you are trying to
fight some kind of a passive-aggressive
emotional war with these people
when their [ __ ] son just died
is so [ __ ] up well guess what the
the brother from seattle is a younger
brother my younger brother comes to the
attic to console me about her older
brother
of course he recorded it
sun chips here we go
it says applause the closed caption said
it was a clause that you hear now
oh that's very funny here we go turn up
there's food downstairs if you want
there's food downstairs if you want
all right we're almost different right
now
trying to work on a film project for a
project
uh um
i'm trying to work on a uh uh
it's an art project yeah actually why
don't we do the air conditioning
uh they removed in a long time and i
don't want to get cold because they get
cold
recording [ __ ] it's just so gay
still sucks
what's funny about dane two is how tough
he how tough you see tough in those
facebook posts
but the moment his younger brother shows
up he's all timid he's all timid he's a
little timid boy
he never actually does the things he
says in his post like he always like oh
i confronted no you didn't
just think about that about the shitty
times to think about
just thinking about the shitty times i
hope it's not
i don't know what to do but
i hope you can come down and eat some
food at least
you look good how long your skin looks
like
i mean right here is it yeah i'm
changing
that
listen to how kind his brother's being
look how kind he's trying to be this guy
is such a [ __ ]
there's such a big disconnect i hate
i hate earl yeah i
i heard about it before but it
i don't know also i read on an article
actually recently
i haven't i'm not sure i don't know
as far as a natural
you should be high up on the list for a
vaccination though
if you want it vaccination i would think
i don't know i don't i guess i didn't
look at the long list
[Music]
please get the vaccine please get it i i
need
i need to just hope on the off chance
that he's just one of those one and one
i i need bell's palsy date and hypernova
in my life
this this is you know crazy to me is
that his brother died and all he's
talking he's trying to just change the
subject to talk about anything else
because he can't be a human
no he's incapable of it
because i was looking my girlfriend
uh has like severe asthma but
she apparently isn't on it so i don't
know
i'm not sure what the actual criteria
are but i think it's worth looking into
yeah they have the vaccine like uh well
they i know
some people also sorry i just just a
question here
he's got to be there's got to be a part
of of of dayton that's that's
completely devastated because this was
it
this is the way i see like the trump
reply guys
are so happy that trump's gone because
it hasn't actually sunk in yet that
without him some of these people
have no identity like there's a whole
swath of lefty twitter accounts
who have based every single thing
they've done on trump for four years and
they're like yeah he's finally gone
but now it's starting to sink in like oh
god oh god i have no there's nothing
interesting about me oh god so like he's
got nothing now
without the beat without crying about
the beatings
which is his only identity that he's had
for for the entire time we've been
covering him
now he has nothing now he's got nothing
like earl should be devastated right now
well here you go but
um well data if you want to talk
i know i know there's a lot
a lot of shitty things
and i mean but
if you want to chat i'll be here until
monday at least
bro so this is the remember the brother
he was criticizing the other one who
came
evil dude if you want to chat another
was a lot of shitty things i have to go
i have to leave monday uh so i wish i
could stay longer but
i already have had my appointment for
the second shot
uh so that's the main reason i have to
go back
let me work but i can do that remote
um hopefully again well there's wings i
don't know if you
eat wings
sorry cj in the chat
sherman dying as trump leaves is like
the dog so loyal it dies when its master
does
beautiful god you're right
says now it's going to be my brother's
haunting me in this house yeah he's
beating his now my brother's ghosts is
beating me
are you called up no okay really uh
it's not that cool to me anyway i don't
know
sometimes okay
you know what sucks too is like there's
there is
he's a shitty person through and through
of course but he also is genuinely
mentally ill
oh yeah both the fact that they've just
let it go completely untreated all this
time
and you know that's another problem and
i think you're gonna see more of this in
the future
in our country is and i'm not
i'm not trying to break toss here i'm
just saying that you know
uh there is some overlap when it comes
to
people and mental illness like
i'm not i'm not susan easy
i'm not saying being is a mental illness
i am saying
that there are people and there are
mentally ill people
and there's overlap and what's going to
happen is
you're not allowed to bring it up now
because people are going to go oh
because i'm because i'm a woman and
you're like
no i'm saying that you're exhibiting
other behaviors
that you might want to get and now like
we're going to leave people completely
untreated from all these
these issues because they can hide
behind
the thing and when you go well i'm not
saying because you think you're a woman
i'm
saying it's because your your brother
died and you're making it all about you
and you're still complaining about your
family and meanwhile
like you're not handling this situation
the way a sane person would handle it
but they'll always have all because i'm
so hyped
so now people are just there are doctors
out there that are now going to be
very very hesitant to diagnose people
with
real issues because they're like i don't
want to lose my medical license like i
don't want to end up on
[ __ ] i don't want to end up on some
viral twitter thread that buzzfeed
writes a [ __ ] article about and then
i
like and then the california medical
board comes and takes my license away
like these are all real realities so
this is [ __ ] terrible
it's sad he's obviously
he's obviously in the next life
he just talks so i don't know
maybe i talk similar to him and don't
think about her don't realize it
ah it just seems like he's high
strong yeah he's definitely high strung
maybe it is just because he's home and
it's awkward
and
there's a reason why that guy ignores
text messages about
violence at home because you're
constantly
making [ __ ] up yeah you're the you're
the guy you're the guy who [ __ ]
cries beatings you can't keep doing it
over and over again and expect everyone
to [ __ ]
you know believe you every time
sitting in my bedroom as my as my elder
brothers wake downstairs
uh con contended
at my absence
so it's just him secretly recording
basically so it doesn't matter whatever
that's it
so that's the update on dayton i i
needed i needed to get through it